é bom aproveitar que estamos hoje aí
nesse findi tarde de primavera uma velha
de uns 40 graus nessa primavera que joão
pessoa pra contar pra vocês uma história
em uma outra primavera primavera de -5
graus que eu passei estou com um foram
alguns anos planejando essa viagem que é
como intuito fazer um curso de
estratégia digital uma das escolas mais
famosos do mundo
então fui lá o objetivo de aprender lá
na suécia aprendi muito a lhe adquirir
bastante conhecimento mas também
aprender outras coisas bem inusitadas
lá aprendi que suecos fazem filas
aleatórias nas ruas
aprendi que alguns não acham que
colombianos e brasileiros falam a mesma
língua
aprendi que é proibido beber na rua lá e
essa história da nas filas e aleatórias
aconteceu num dia estava fazendo esse
menos 5 graus
eu acordei para a aula e no caminhão e
dei de cara com a fila e isso é todos em
casa caso
no sentido oposto ao do ponto de ônibus
entende muito mas estava chegando a não
quis contrariar a cultura local foi
fiquei na fila
resultado o riso de vocês já já
beneficia acabei perdendo um ônibus e aí
observando em outros casos
vi que esse comportamento se repetir
sete olhos fechados pois pra cima
parados e sem praças e outros pontos de
ônibus
marx ea um certo dia estava saindo do
mercado
viviam um lado do metrô sentei na praça
um banco da praça
de repente sentir no estado do meu rosto
que aquecer um filho de menos 5 graus
aquela sensação quem tinha é bem
acolhedora então já levantei olhei
estava lá não ônibus que eu tinha
perdido mas o sol então já me preocupo
já me preparei me ajeitar para
aproveitar aquela respeita resta de sol
da primavera sueca e sol que aqui a
gente
em joão pessoa a gente vê todo dia 1º
sem nem tanto a cerimônia
lá na suécia é digno de contorcionismo
para aproveitar os poucos momentos que
dá o ar da graça em filas aleatórias na
suécia
médicos que atendem por ordem de chegada
em joão pessoa
o problema de uma comunidade que a gente
acredita não ter uma solução
os casos só são compreendidos quando a
gente adota uma postura dessa postura
simpatia empatia essa coisa de a gente
olhar com o olhar dos outros a gente
sentir tentar científico que os outros
sentem
ela é muito importante porque a gente é
programado desde cedo achar que nossas
idéias são sempre melhores que é o nosso
olhar que vai engordar o gado
quando na verdade uma ideia ela só vai
pra frente
quando ela viu quando ela é vista pelos
olhos de outras pessoas
não existe mais essa época do fazer
primeiro o facebook não foi a primeira
rede social
o tesla não é o primeiro carro elétrico
e podem ter certeza que vocês não são a
primeira pessoa que pensou na ideia que
pode mudar o mundo
não há compartilhamento não há
crescimento sem compartilhamento
hum
não aprendizagem aprendizado sem
conexões das suas ideias cheguem aos
outros é preciso que você compartilhe e
podem ter certeza não é o olhar de vocês
que vai engordar o gado
eu descobri isso quando estava voltando
às suas a reencontrar nosso bom e velho
só de uma pessoa e ao chegar aqui eu nem
começou e nós queremos colocar nossas
competências da prova e saiu em busca de
idéias que fossem realmente inovadoras é
nós somos acostumados a desenvolver
idéias criar produzir avaliar e idéias
para nossos clientes
nós somos especialistas em criar coisas
que ajudam nossos clientes a se
comunicarem melhor com os consumidores
deles mas nós sempre fazendo isso com o
nosso trabalho
nós nunca colocamos à prova e idéias que
pudessem estranhar pessoas assim como eu
estranhei que elas filhos aleatórias
digital comum e essas idéias
a gente precisava deixar de olhar um
pouco o nosso umbigo tá encontrá las
sendo assim a gente decidiu ir buscá las
num lugar que hoje em dia acaba sendo
menos buscado
a universidade
nós começamos fazendo uma pesquisa para
entender
utilizamos o google maior ferramenta de
busca do mundo a entender a relação da
universidade com a inovação a nossa
tristeza descobriu que essa relação vem
caindo drasticamente nas percepções
através das músicas
a universidade isso mesmo
a academia é engraçado a gente imaginar
que as buscas por inovação vem crescendo
cada dia mais e cada vez menos
ela buscava na universidade
isso é um não é um fato que acontece só
aqui no brasil
na verdade mundial enfim nós percebemos
isso mas mesmo assim decidimos separar
universitário atrás dessas idéias porque
por empatia nós nós percebemos que a
ideia que a universidade ela é criativa
não gostar dela inovadora existem
projetos criativos e inovadores lá porém
o problema a que se essas idéias são
visíveis e invisíveis à academia mas
podem ser de grande valia ao mercado
então decidimos
unir a nossa visão o que eu tinha
aprendido sobre estratégia digital
montamos apresentações e começamos a
participar de eventos em diversas áreas
design computação comunicação tecnologia
de alimentos em busca trás dessa idéia
inovadora
então certo dia estamos conversando com
dois professores parceiros nós quando de
repente no meio da conversa eu senti
aquele calor da descoberta igual como
incentivo à na suécia
eles falavam de um projecto e um
trabalho de conclusão de curso de dois
alunos um ano de engenharia elétrica e
outro de produção mecânica em conta
gotas para deficientes visuais
é um projeto técnico
é interessante que a proposta de levar
através de um de um tubo há uma gota a
passar por um sensor ótico que quando
tinha seu sinal cortado disparava um bip
além disso esse produto tinha como
objetivo atender 18,8 por cento da
população brasileira são esse é o número
de pessoas que possuem alguma
deficiência visual
bem é um produto que percebe que tem um
nome no mercado
mas aí talvez alguns já deve estar se
perguntando
ela estava falando empatia e agora já
está falando o mercado vai falar do
negócio de dinheiro em primeiro turno
o fato principal é que um conta gotas
para deficientes visuais
desenvolvido por alunos que não possuem
deficiência é sempre sente empatia eles
não tendo esse problema é detectar um
problema que às vezes nem o próprio
deficiente visual
imagina pode ser resolvida além disso
esse produto
ele precisava ele precisava de algo mais
ele precisava deixar de ser uma
tecnologia pra ir pra chegar na mão das
pessoas
ele precisava o modelo de negócio
precisava de design produto vocês sabem
como faz isso com empatia é você se
colocar no lugar de um pai deficiente
visual tem que acordar de madrugada para
a organização um filho que está com três
de asma e encerrar o medicamento 15
gotas em pode levar o filho a própria
morte
estão começando a entender já né
e aí uma pergunta pra vocês vocês
tomaram a dosagem errada do medicamento
talvez dependendo do medicamento e da
dosagem errada para o filho de vocês já
estão começando a ver o problema com a
empatia mas então como princípio como
gente precisava de dinheiro para
levantar esse projeto vamos atrás disso
começamos a trabalhar com ele e cheio de
disposição coragem começamos a correr
atrás de investimento
inscrevemos eles e se o conta gotas em
um dois três quatro cinco problemas
dessa era de aceleração no brasil fora
do brasil e do resultado nada
e como é que um produto desse podia
gerar um impacto tão grande na vida das
pessoas e tem um potencial do mercado
tão grande não estava sendo percebido
pelas pessoas que avaliavam como um
produto é realmente bom
bem usamos a empatia pra isso
a verdade é que eles não estavam vendo o
que nós estamos estamos estávamos vendo
o quanto a gente via tudo isso todo esse
potencial
eles viam isso um produto com tecnologia
tamanho de aproximadamente um copo
plástico que mais parece uma miniatura
de módulo lunar cuja única função da
eles era emitir um bip
toda vez que uma gota passasse dentro
dele sabemos que o país precisava de um
algo mais para ser visto pelas outras
pessoas
ele precisava nova rodada de olhares e
então essa história partir daí acaba
voltando pra europa agora só que dessa
vez não precisa cruzar o atlântico
só precisei aguentar e trânsito zinho
ter um pouco de paciência na no trânsito
de recife onde fomos apresentar conta
gotas a um parceiro nosso
o engenheiro holandês líder de uma
empresa de design da holanda
nós apresentamos pra ele não uma duas
vezes esse produto com a intenção de que
ele percebesse o que a gente tinha
percebido o que a gente sabia que sem a
ajuda dele a gente não conseguiria dar
um passo seguinte com conta gotas e ele
conseguiu enxergar isso não só enxergou
como materializou o que a gente buscava
a conta gotas
agora existia um design holandês e com
ele vieram também funcionalidades
facilitavam pessoas não totalmente cegas
mas com baixa visão de adquirir um
produto já que ele já que ele tinha
cores fortes e contrastantes
tecnicamente ele se tornou mais simples
o seu canal diminuiu e assim evitava com
um que eu conheço alguma perda de
gordura além disso em outras
contribuições relacionadas à percepção
das pessoas
ele não parece em nada com o equipamento
médico e isso não foi à toa que foi
pensado pra que defende que deficiente
visual pudesse tirar do bolso uma praça
de alimentação e utilizar sem nenhum
problema sem que as outras pessoas
olhassem com estranheza essa inclusão
além disso o conta gotas teve uma
ajudinha cultural
vinda direto da holanda
esse é o trunfo um doce que é consumido
antes de consumir a gente coloca acima
do 1 xícara de café ou chá pra quem
escreve e essa influência vai ajudar
aquele pai que a gente lá atrás que
precisa ter uma mão livre para segurar a
criança filho dele ea outra é usar o
medicamento bem agora conta gotas está
bonito e aí agora as pessoas vão
enxergar ele prova disso é que vocês
estão aqui hoje escutando essa história
que eu tô contando que não pode parar
aqui conta gotas
ele precisa ir mais longe mas não só
pelo conta gotas
mas por causa da empatia que a gente
precisa olhar para as ideias dos outros
e compartilhar nossas ideias porque a
conta gotas chegou nesse ponto lá atrás
essa idéia foi compartilhada por uma
pessoa e foi vista por outra
compartilhada por uma pessoa de vista
por outra e assim que as idéias crescem
vocês ainda vão falar mas vou ouvir
muito falar desse conta gotas
porque ele atende 11 problema muito
maior
vocês acham que o problema é que ele é
conta-gotas precisa um pouco mais de
empatia que ele só funciona entre as
dependências inclusão